how's it going everybody it's will learn
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about everything
relating to the MCU and today we have
some really big news about Mark
Ruffalo's Hulk in the MCU now we know
that a she-hulk
Disney Plus Marvel studio series is
coming but we really haven't heard
anything after Avengers endgame about
the Hulk in the MCU but today we have a
lot more information thanks to Mark
Ruffalo himself yesterday was c2e2 the
Chicago Comic Con and Entertainment Expo
and Mark Ruffalo himself showed up and
talked about the future of the Hulk and
from what he said it looks like the
future is very very bright for the Hulk
and the MCU so we're going to go over
everything that he talked about
everything that was revealed yesterday
and that is him returning to the MCU a
solo hulk film and who truly owns the
rights to a solo Hulk film Universal or
Marvel Studios preliminary talks about
him appearing as the Hulk in the
she-hulk Disney Plus series and of
course Hulk vs. Wolverine if you're new
be sure to subscribe to stay up to date
on everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking
a winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers just be sure to
subscribe like the video and comment
down below so to start off at c2e2 Mark
Ruffalo actually talked about what he
himself would like to see Bruce Banner
slash the Hulk do in the MCU he
described where this new movie or show
would start off at after Avengers in
game and where he'd want to take it now
he revealed yesterday that Universal
actually still does own the rights to a
solo hulk film there was some talks a
couple of months ago that stated that
the rights to the hulk may have gone
back to marvel studios but Mark Ruffalo
made it very clear that Universal still
has those rights to a solo film so Mark
Ruffalo said that if they were to do a
solo hulk project it would have to be a
show either on disney plus or elsewhere
he revealed that even though Universal
owns the rights to the solo property
they can do a solo home project if it's
streaming or on a TV series which he
said he would do given the opportunity
to lend his creative chops to a series
of whether it be on Disney Plus or
television he said maybe we make it into
a series and we jump through the
universal universal owns the rights to
the Hulk as a standalone movie so that's
really why we can't make one but we can
do a TV show and this is where Mark
Ruffalo states that if he had his way
for the Hulk TV show this is how he
would do it and keep in mind Mark
Ruffalo has met with Kevin Feige at
least a couple of times that we know of
to talk about the hoax feature in the
MCU so this very well could be what we
can expect when talking about what a
Hulk TV show would look like he said I'd
probably kind of start him off on the
run again a little bit I think that
really works and in this new digital age
were all surveilled that might be kind
of an interesting dimension to how he
stays on the run that's probably where
we'd start him deciding I don't want to
do this anymore
but it's hard now because he's the
professor he's hard to hide this is a
little bit of a different direction than
I think most people expected the Hulk
story arc to continue from it's after
Avengers in game he performed the snap
his arms hurt but he brought everybody
back and it is professor Hulk it's not
the normal Hulk that we know and Mark
Ruffalo makes it very clear here that
the Hulk that we have right now
currently after Avengers in game is
still Professor Hulk but the Hulk being
on the run is a reoccurring storyline
from the comics and according to Mark
Ruffalo that's something that we could
see play out on-screen in a series now
it is worth noting that Mark Ruffalo
does not say Disney Plus he simply says
television show and this is because it
is possible for the whole to get a TV
show that's not on Disney Plus recently
ABC has revealed that they are talking
with Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios about developing a Marvel TV
series for their network so it is very
well possible that the plans for the
whole television show could be on this
network because we know that there are a
lot of Disney Plus shows coming and Mark
Ruffalo stated that he is probably going
to be on the she-hulk series at the expo
he said there is talk about his Hulk
potentially showing up in the she-hulk
series but talks are preliminary so
they're talking about working him into
the she hope series which makes perfect
sense because in the comics Jennifer
Walters is Bruce banners cousin she gets
in an accident and in order to save her
life Bruce Banner does a blood
transfusion with her and she gets the
ability to turn into she-hulk so it
makes sense that he would be in it but
of course the
big bomb was about Hulk vs. Wolverine
now keep in mind that even though
Universal owns the rights to a Hope Solo
film that doesn't mean that the Hulk
can't show up in a movie it simply has
to be a team-up movie and they can't
name the movie The Hulk this is why the
Hulk was able to be in Thor Ragnarok it
was really a Thor and Hulk film but they
called it Thor Ragnarok which allowed
him to be in the film
so they still can do a movie that has
the Hulk and Wolverine in it and Mark
Ruffalo said that he wants to do it he
went on to say in the expo to be totally
honest with you I want to see the movie
where Banner and Hulk ultimately have to
battle it out and then the professor is
sort of a brainchild of that he went on
to say Kevin Feige are you listening we
want professor Hulk the only person in
the universe that Hulk is afraid of is
banner and I want to see the ultimate
showdown between the two of them and
maybe Wolverine this is not the first
time that Mark Ruffalo has stated that
he wants to do a film with Wolverine now
the first part of what he said is
talking about the Hulk and banner he
wants to see that dynamic play out but
that's not what a whole entire movie is
going to be about because they still are
the same person right they're still the
same body the Hulk can't fight Bruce
Banner physically because they are one
body so when he talks about he wants to
see that and then Wolverine that's all
the same film perhaps Wolverine is the
only person who can truly get the Hulk
to come out again now that Bruce Banner
and the Hulk are Professor Hulk everyone
of course was pretty disappointed that
in Avengers in game we didn't get to see
the Hulk Hulk out and based off of
everything that we know that's done for
the most part professor Hulk is in
control of his anger Banner actually did
a pretty lousy job of acting like the
Hulk hulking out so if we want to
revisit the true nature of the Hulk the
angry Hulk smash machine someone or
something is going to have to bring that
out and that person of course is
Wolverine a lot of us expected it when
not died in Avengers in game but that
didn't happen and that would really be
the only other thing that could get the
Hulk to Hulk out so we're left with
Wolverine and now of course Disney and
Marvel Studios owned the rights to the
x-men at the Fantastic Four Doctor Doom
and Galactus and Kevin Feige officially
mentioned at same
Comic Con that the mutants are headed to
the MCU but we know that Marvel Studios
does not want to be the same as the Fox
x-men and we know they're not going to
introduce them in one big x-men film
they're going to gradually introduce the
x-men in other films first and again
this is not the first time that Mark
Ruffalo has mentioned that he wants to
do a Wolverine film and there have been
reports in the past that have said
Marvel Studios
is considering doing a Hulk vs.
Wolverine film back last year in August
of 2019 Mikey sudden an insider and the
community posted about a Hulk vs.
Wolverine film and he said in a post
I've been hearing this for a while now
but the smoke is becoming a red hot fire
Marvel Studios is discussing a Wolverine
versus Hulk film notice I placed
Wolverine ahead this won't be a Hulk
movie because Universal has the rights
to a Hulk solo film which is why Thor
Ragnarok wasn't Planet Hulk because
basically it was the Planet Hulk
storyline according to my inside sources
they want to use the recent immortal
Hulk rendition of the character in the
comic books who will be Wolverine or
depending on many years this will take
is Mark Ruffalo still the Hulk well
considering the fact that Mark Ruffalo
yesterday was talking about returning to
the MCU and reprising his role as Bruce
Banner slashed the Hulk possibly in an
upcoming TV show or team-up film and he
mentioned Wolverine I'm guessing that
he's still going to be playing the Hulk
and according to Mikey this has been
talked about for some time now and Mark
Ruffalo has name-dropped Wolverine in an
interview that was documented twice so
it certainly seems like this is
definitely something that could possibly
happen if everything goes right and
again Mikey's words were very careful he
put Wolverine in front of the Hulk
because as Mark Ruffalo just said
yesterday Universal still does own the
rights to a solo Hulk film but this does
not mean that he cannot appear in a
team-up film so this is very possible
and then not to mention we have reports
that Red Hulk is going to be coming to
the MCU as well via the Thunderbolts and
this doesn't really come as that big of
a surprise either Thunderbolt Ross has
been a part of the MCU since the very
beginning since the Incredible Hulk and
ever since then in the MCU and of course
in the comics he wants to get his
on super serum and of course the side
effects of him experimenting with the
serum on himself turned him into Red
Hulk in the Black Widow trailer they
showed a Thunderbolt Ross and it's
widely expected that the Black Widow
film is going to have to do with this
serum the serum is most likely going to
be used to enhance the black widows and
this is most likely wife Thunderbolt
Ross is going to be in the movie that
and to hunt Natasha down after the
sokovia chords but they do show him in
the past there's an incredibly young D
aged version of him in the trailer and
this is most likely when he is looking
for that super serum and this will lead
into the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series which is reported to introduce
the Thunderbolts which is where we will
see Red Hulk so it's also very possible
that we could see the Hulk go up against
the Red Hulk so as you can see there are
just tons of possibilities about the
future of the Hulk and the MCU and Mark
Ruffalo is seemingly very open about
returning to play the character and he
has a lot of ideas about what they can
do with his story arc we know that he's
met with Kevin Feige a couple of times
and we know that in between he said that
he'd like to see a Wolverine film he has
since then met with Kevin Feige and we
know the mutants are coming to the MCU
so hopefully a Hulk vs. Wolverine film
could happen and it seems like when this
film does happen Mark Ruffalo is going
to be the Hulk so who would you like to
see play Wolverine there's a lot of
talks about Henry Cavill rumored to be
meeting with Marvel Studios about
playing Wolverine but who would you like
to see let me know in the comments down
below don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe when notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU join my
discord if you'd like to talk about
Marvel to fellow superhero lovers and
don't forget to follow me on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof